freddie mercury whose 75th birthday
would have been today and okay so the
rule is that they have 15 minutes in
between games these two must have had an
agreement to only have 10 minutes
because here we go game three david yep
breathless action
it's the sicilian defense and uh yeah
one of the most counter-attacking
openings for black remember artemis
needs to win and uh right now he is
thinking he needs to pick a variation
will it be the sicilian night off will
it be yes it is the sicilian night off
uh he doesn't choose the dragon the
shave in england the classical so many
branches of the sicilian he could have
picked but he chooses the most popular
opening in chess pretty much funky queen
move where he's moved the queen two
squares now he chooses to develop his
light square bishop so one of the most
traditional moves one of the most calm
kind of composed moves you can play in
the sicilian night off just developing
the bishop getting ready to castle the
white king i'll tell you he mentioned
he's changing up his opening strategy
and talking of changing things up we
went from the sicilian night off which
is to push black's a pawn there but now
black has pushed another pawn and this
is going to be a hybrid of the
sicilian night off and the sicilian
dragon and it's what we call the
dragodorf so he can pick up his h pawn
and move it one square that's on the
board another alternative was actually
to provoke that pawn to come forward and
push the age pawn two squares now i
expect to see magnus continue with peace
development one thing magnus okay he
does bring his pushback one thing magnus
can't do and definitely won't do is
castle the white king over to the right
side now he's just weakened that flank
too much artemis definitely trying
something new he knows he needs to what
he's been doing so far hasn't worked and
that's just good advice for any player
if your strategy isn't working if you're
banging your head against that door and
you're not breaking through from
advancing even further he does he
prevents any potential annoyances
against that white knight five minutes
to spare
okay the bishop has developed two is
long diagonal and we're expecting magnus
to step forward with the queen so we're
asking if you had your kingdom who would
be the king and queen
and
there you go magnus makes the move my
king and queen boring words from magnus
carlsen magnus
developing his knight definitely that
was a lot of fun okay and now magnus has
castled to the long side with his king
they're lined up against the pawn on
that side of the warden
you
these guys are just joining in our
storytelling today exactly it's beth's
turn to shine and she has pushed forward
this has initiated some real
complications uh but i'll tell you if he
needs to go for this type of gamble if
you give magnus garcon too much time to
stabilize there's not much chance you'll
be able to create a decisive attack so
he thinks that this is the moment but it
does come with a ring yeah i was just
gonna say two captures on the board
which one would you choose magnus has
decided for us knight takes knight
yeah and there were actually two choices
there for black on the last turn black
then didn't necessarily need to capture
back that night he could have captured
the other uh white knight with beth the
b pawn targets that means four blacks
pieces yeah and black screen does go
across to try and target white weak
pawns on this left side if he draws
that's it okay we do have uh the knight
move that you highlighted there it's his
favorite maneuver stockfish's second
suggestion oh it was until suddenly that
queen moved ivanka as soon as you
mentioned it disappeared from the top
three suggestions so maybe there was a
downside but we didn't find out we saw
black's bishop instead eliminate that
white knight this wasn't the number one
suggestion it wasn't even the number two
suggestion but it has meant that black
has got some time to advance some pawns
yeah and artemis trying to open up lines
and magnus says no and now
it's anna again
but this time is desperately trying to
open up lines and magnus now playing a
great move you could eliminate this pawn
if you want to be really safe okay black
meanwhile castling but i was going to
say this theme is going to continue if
magnus had seen this pawn push forward
maybe he would push his own pawn just
keeping his king nice and safe and this
idea will remain over the next few turns
and magnus i mentioned the king might be
the best blockader he's put his king
across good strategy again when you cast
it on the long side and now if the pawn
pushes forward magnus will just block
things up either with a pawn push one
square or two squares both seem fine and
next move use his king as a blockader
but either way it's making magnus happy
and will that translate into a result so
okay that pawn has much forward so this
is the acid test of white's whole system
we did see white just bypass that one
yeah block it up stepping forward with
the queen another one would be just
moving okay
this one
was also that
but what's the point there's no way into
white's camp
okay there we go magnus has pushed his
pawns forward look at all those white
pawns all on light squares all
protecting each other yeah they're gonna
be backed up by white's king soon okay
black has given a check so the white
king in the corner the viking vulnerable
on dark squares but that's why white's
dark square bishop is such a key piece
give him something to think about and
okay black gets ready to push the pawn
you wanted to ivanka he brings this rook
across first
okay that makes some sense definitely
makes some sense because now the pawn
push will come with some potential extra
power
oh
it's magnus trying to kill the game you
know anything that artemyev is doing
he's saying i can do better yep bringing
his last piece at the party yeah
sensible stuff that's why magnus is so
good at speech s as well as classical
because he plays simple moves
pawn takes pawn rotates pawn on the
board so the white light squared bishop
might step out of the way now and try to
initiate some rook traits ever gets into
an end game say the queens get traded
off
the a pawn black's pride and joy will
just simply fall off the board where to
buy this lovely chess set in front of us
actually this is a play magnus chess set
and i am absolutely sure you can buy it
online so that way unless artemiev comes
up with a really miraculous resource or
tricks magnus with something really
cunning i agree with absolutely
everything you said
but if there's always a button yeah
there's always okay but if you were
artemia and you need to go into james
bond mode right now to save the day
is this the correct way to initiate
some kind of action
it's difficult because it's just a way
up of the odds right okay he's traded
rooks meanwhile um because
every move looks pretty i mean there's
no way to save the game i think now with
black you're simply losing you just have
to
try and gamble what will magnus feel
least comfortable with where can i set a
trap i don't see any traps right now i
don't see magnus being uncomfortable but
does that mean that this idea is a
failure or does that mean there was just
nothing else i'm not sure well there's
there's a problem in this position that
white is attacking the knight
and black has been forced onto the
defensive to defend this knight use the
black rook or use the black queen to get
rid of white's queen or bishop then
maybe some small chances one of the
things about this whole format is that
i'll tell you if gets experienced
you know he was he was here as a kind of
wild card
and then he ended up coming in second
place and then third place and then
now challenging again for the first i
had options
just thinking the the h line um okay
magnus using brute force instead i liked
your your move there ivanka but magnus
giving up a pawn in order to free up
another pawn so if black takes that
white pawn
then gary the g pawn is gonna march
forward
gary brother of harry yes yeah
sacrificed itself and we have seen a
queen sacrifice actually from mateo tell
me if he gave up his queen for white's
bishop in the center of the board he had
to everything else was losing but it was
only a temporary sacrifice because now
black's knight has jumped out the way oh
that's nice by magnus
black's knight jumped out the way
unleashing the black bishop again it's
created a pin against the white queen
and king and you mentioned you got
excited here ivanka the bishop took the
pawn black's king could not capture that
bishop because white's rook would have
come up and given a deadly check
deflecting the black king away from the
defense of its bishop so artemis had to
play this move and now magnus so cynical
just trading off the rooks he's heading
for the end game
oh this is going to kill i think all
chances fought him yeah
and uh after rook takes rook queen takes
bishop
everything is under control for the
world champion he will for sure have a
big say in who wins the tour final
and uh here comes the race of the pawns
yup and notice this last move by white
it has freed up a square for white
bishop to use so white's bishop will
utilize the square that that white pawn
previously sat on in order to drop back
and stop freddie the f-pawn so white's
bishop okay we won't see it yet but um
white bishop can drop back now i think
has 10 minutes on the clock he can
work everything out so he pushes his
pawn and
now i'm gonna suspect that artemia
delivers a check he takes born and
maybe his idea is just to give another
check and then
guard the pawn yeah so
preventing beth from getting coronated
from becoming a new queen
but look at white's bishop now this is
what we call the night stable we learned
from simon williams the ginger gm when
he was trolling us
oh
too many pawns for white yeah and i'll
tell me f
setting
one final trick which probably doesn't
even work but okay magnus cautiously
advancing his king
and it's headed towards the c6 square
one step closer to the knight and
yeah white's king notice how it's
staying out of any potential checks and
i hear i expect to see white
okay i thought it was going to move the
bishop yeah white's bishop could move
white's king can now go
kind of the long way around to support
beth marching forward there we go
that pawn is going to become a new queen
it's going to cost black a knight and
look right we'll still have two
remaining pawns gary and beth
yeah it's just too many pawns here and
black's pawn
under lock and key
yeah i must say a superb performance
from the world champion today
yeah i'll tell you if he's done well but
he hasn't really stood a chance
unfortunately he's tried his best but it
hasn't been enough and now look at this
one pawn marches forward one is blocked
the other goes and that causes artemis
to resign
magnus carlsen is the winner of the aim
chess u.s uh rapid his third tournament
victory in the meltwater champions chess
tour 2021 a dominant performance here in
the final by the world champion